side by side at rome's famous trevi
fountain french president emmanuel
macron and british prime minister boris
johnson appeared to be in good humour
but behind the smiles the escalating
tensions between their two countries
showed no sign of letting up a meeting
away from the cameras failing to bring
them closer to agreement
now the ball is in their court if the
british don't make a move obviously the
measures that are planned from the 2nd
of november onwards will have to be put
in place because it will be a no-go the
ball is in britain's court
france has accused the uk of flouting a
post-brexit trade deal by failing to
give french fishermen enough licences to
operate in british waters and outlined a
series of sanctions if they weren't
granted
if the dispute is not resolved by
tuesday france will go ahead with a
series of what it's called targeted
measures at ports like this along the
coast british fishing vessels will
undergo strictest security checks and
they may not be able to dock to unload
their catch they'll also be longer time
consuming health and safety checks for
trucks going to or from the uk
caught up in the debate this british
trawler it was seized off the port of le
havre on thursday its captain accused of
fishing in french waters without a
license
the company that owns the boat says it's
being used as a pawn in the dispute the
british prime minister has said the
seizure wasn't what he'd expect from a
close friend and ally and that it's up
to france to step back from its threats
on fish i've got to tell you the the
position is is unchanged and uh you know
uh i would i'll just i'll just i'll just
say this uh for the for the record i
must say i was puzzled to read a a
letter from the french prime minister
explicitly asking for britain to be
punished for leaving the eu
and i i i just have to say i don't
believe that that is compatible either
with the uh the spirit or the letter of
the withdrawal agreement
relations between the uk and france
clearly navigating troubled waters with
both sides determined to hold their
course
alexia o'brien al jazeera paris